The secrets of happiness
1. Stop being so hopeful
Expect that most things are going to go wrong
marriage, job, holidays, kids
Look at the glass half empty and then feel grateful
Whenever things aren't quite catastrophic
2. Stop ranting about how awful other people are
Most annoying people aren't evil, they're just anxious or sad
Forgive them. They don't set out to hurt you
They are just under a lot of pressure
3. Think of Death a lot
Keep a skull on your table. You probably only got about 400,000 hours left
4. Love yourself
Stop thinking of yourself as a stupid idiot
Do something fun and nicer: a loveable fool
5. Make regular appointments to talk with someone you don't spend enough time with... you
Ask yourself what you really want and are anxious about
6. Stop trying to make yourself happy, it's impossible
Concentrate on cheering up other people
7. Look at yourself as differently i.e. 240 miles above the Earth
From this height, lots of things that are bothering you look the size they should always've been
8. Throw your phone of a cliff for a bit
So you can finally notice stuff
Specially your partner and your mom.
9. Give up on the idea that you should be normal
The only normal people are people you don't know yet
Everyone is weird and that's totally ok